breaking news at 11 o'clock tonight
Metro Police and a standoff with a man
barricaded inside of a shopping center
this happening near Tropicana and McLeod
police say the man is armed and making
threats and refusing to come out eight
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough is
there with what's unfolding right now
[Music]
yeah it's an active scene out here I
want you to take a look behind me as you
can see the whole shopping center that's
on McLeod is taped off believing that
that's the Walmart shopping center near
the Dollar Tree Metro stating that they
have not been able to safely take the
man into custody currently SWAT is
responding but it's unclear where the
incident initially started as of now
East and Westbound Lanes of Tropicana
are shut down at the 3000 block McLeod
is also shut down from Tropicana to Key
Largo of course make sure to keep it on
8 news now but specifically
eightnewsnow.com for the latest updates
and information reporting here live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now